BREAKING NEWS NIGHT.
BIG BREAKING NEWS OPENING
MONOLOGUE
♪
>> Sean: TONIGHT WE HAVE
EXPLOSIVE NEW CHAPTER IN
MULLER'S WITCH-HUNT.
WE HAVE ENTERED A DANGEROUS
PHASE.
THERE IS NO TURNING BACK
FROM THIS.
IT IS CLEAR AS I HAVE BEEN
WARNING, MUELLER IS OUT TO
GET THE PRESIDENT AND IT
APPEARS AT ANY COST.
HERE IS WHAT HAPPENED.
UPON REFERRAL FROM SPECIAL
COUNSELOR ROBERT MUELLER,
THE FBI HAS RAIDED THE
OFFICE, THE HOME AND THE
HOTEL ROOM OF MICHAEL COHEN.
THE PERSONAL ATTORNEY OF THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES.
NOW, THE FBI REPORTEDLY
SEIZED RECORDS RELATED TO
COHEN'S PAYMENT TO THIS PORN
STAR STORMY DANIELS AND
OTHER ITEMS.
ACCORDING TO BLOOMBERG
TONIGHT.
THIS ALL CAME AFTER THE
DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL ROD
ROSENSTEIN RECOMMEND DOLLARS
THAT THE COHEN INVESTIGATION
BE PURSUED BY FEDERAL
PROSECUTORS IN NEW YORK.
NOW, KEEP IN MIND.
COHEN WAS NEVER PART OF THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION OR THE
THIS IS NOW OFFICIALLY AN
ALL HANDS ON DECK EFFORT TO
TOTALLY MALIGN AND, IF
POSSIBLE, IMPEACH THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES.
NOW, MUELLER AND ROSENSTEIN
HAVE DECLARED WHAT IS A
LEGAL WAR ON THE PRESIDENT.
AND A SOURCE CLOSE TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP TONIGHT IS
TELLING FOX NEWS THAT
MUELLER'S INVESTIGATION IS
WAY OUT OF CONTROL.
MY MESSAGE TONIGHT TO
MUELLER IS SIMPLE:  IF YOU
HAVE EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION,
ANY AT ALL, SHOW IT TO US OR
END THIS PARTISAN
INVESTIGATION.
THE COUNTRY IS HANGING BY A
THREAD TONIGHT AND YOU DON'T
SEEM TO CARE.
THE SCAWLDZ RUSSIA COLLUSION
INVESTIGATION HAS NOW
EVOLVED FROM A FACELESS
START TO A CRIMINAL
PROSECUTION, LET'S SEE OF
PAUL MANAFORT, FROM A
12-YEAR-OLD PAYMENTS FROM
UKRAINE TO A PAYMENT TO A
PORN STAR NAMED STORMY
DANIELS.
NOW MUELLER AND ROSENSTEIN,
THEY ARE TRULY FULFILLING
THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA'S
FANTASY HERE, AT LEAST
ATTEMPTING TO.
NOW, IN FACT, DESPITE ALL OF
TODAY'S MAJOR BREAKING NEWS,
THE FAKE NEWS WAS TOTALLY
OBSESSED WITH ALL MICHAEL
COHEN.
ULTIMATELY PRESIDENT TRUMP
WAS FORCED TO ADDRESS THIS
COHEN ISSUE DURING A MEETING
WITH MILITARY LEADERS.
HERE'S WHAT HE SAID.
>> SO I JUST HEARD THAT THEY
BROKE INTO THE OFFICE OF ONE
OF MY PERSONAL ATTORNEYS.
GOOD MAN.
AND IT'S A DISGRACEFUL
SITUATION.
IT'S A TOTAL WITCH-HUNT.
I HAVE BEEN SAYING IT FOR A
LONG TIME.
I HAVE WANTED TO KEEP IT
DOWN.
WE HAVE GIVEN, I BELIEVE,
OVER A MILLION PAGES WORTH
OF DOCUMENTS TO THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL.
THEY CONTINUE TO JUST GO
FORWARD AND HERE WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT SYRIA.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT A LOT
OF SERIOUS THINGS WITH THE
GREATEST FIGHTING FORCE
AND I HAVE THIS WITCH-HUNT,
CONSTANTLY GOING ON.
IT'S A DISGRACE.
IT'S FRANKLY A REAL
DISGRACE.
IT'S AN ATTACK ON OUR
COUNTRY IN A TRUE SENSE.
IT'S AN ATTACK ON WHAT WE
ALL STOPPED
STL STOPPED
STANSTOPPED
STANDTOPPED
STAND FPPED
STAND FORED
STAND FOR.D
WHEN I SAW THIS AND HEARD
IT, I HEARD IT LIKE YOU DID,
I SAID THAT IS REALLY NOW IN
A WHOLE NEW LEVEL OF
UNFAIRNESS.
THEY FOUND NO COLLUSION
WHATSOEVER WITH RUSSIA:  THE
REASON THEY FOUND IT WAS
THERE WAS NO COLLUSION AT
ALL.
THIS IS THE MOST BIASED
GROUP OF PEOPLE, THESE
PEOPLE HAVE THE BIGGEST
CONFLICTS OF INTEREST I HAVE
EVER SEEN.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL MADE A
TERRIBLE MISTAKE WHEN HE DID
THIS.
AND WHEN HE RECUSED HIMSELF
OR HE SHOULD HAVE CERTAINLY
LET US KNOW IF HE WAS GOING
TO RECUSE HIMSELF.
AND WE WOULD HAVE USED A --
PUT A DIFFERENT ATTORNEY
GENERAL IN.
WE HAVE HAD THAT HANGING
OVER US NOW FROM THE VERY,
VERY BEGINNING.
AND, YET, THE OTHER SIDE,
THEY DON'T EVEN BOTHER
LOOKING.
AND THE OTHER SIDE IS WHERE
THERE ARE CRIMES.
AND THOSE CRIMES ARE
OBVIOUS.
LIES UNDER OATH.
ALL OVER THE PLACE.
EMAILS THAT ARE KNOCKED OUT,
THAT ARE ACID WASHED AND
DELETED.
NOBODY HAS EVER SEEN.
33,000 EMAILS ARE DELETED
AFTER GETTING A SUBPOENA FOR
CONGRESS.
AND NOBODY BOTHERS LOOKING
AT THAT.
>> Sean: THE PRESIDENT IS
EXACTLY RIGHT.
THIS IS A HUGE MASSIVE
DOUBLE STANDARD.
YOU THINK HILLARY CLINTON'S
ATTORNEYS HAD THEIR OFFICES
RAIDED DURING THIS EMAIL
INVESTIGATION?
NOT A CHANCE.
YOU THINK HILLARY CLINTON'S
LAWYERS, WHERE THEY RAIDED
AFTER IT WAS DETERMINED SHE
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR THAT
PHONY RUSSIAN DOSSIER TO
INFLUENCE THE GENERAL
ELECTION?
NOT A CHANCE.
NO INVESTIGATION.
ANY RAIDS, ANY ARRESTS,
AFTER THE MASSIVE FISA ABUSE
ALLEGATIONS WERE EXPOSED.
NOT A SINGLE CHANCE.
WERE THERE ANY RAIDS, ANY
ARRESTS AFTER HILLARY
CLINTON?
WE KNOW SHE OBSTRUCTED
JUSTICE.
WE KNOW SHE DELETED 33,000
EMAILS.
WE KNOW SHE DELETED ALL OF
THEM AND
THEM TND
THEM THE ACID WASH AS THE
PRESIDENT WAS TALKING ABOUT,
BLEACH BIT AND THEN HAD THE
DEVICES BUSTED UP WITH HAMMERS,
ANYBODY DO ANYTHING THERE?
NOT A CHANCE.
EVERYTHING WE HAVE BEEN
TELLING YOU ABOUT THIS
TWO-TIERED JUSTICE SYSTEM.
WE DON'T HAVE EQUAL JUSTICE
UNDER THE LAW.
IT SHOULD BE IN THE MINDS OF
EVERY AMERICAN CITIZEN
TONIGHT.
ROBERT MUELLER IS SO FAR
BEYOND HIS MANDATE, THIS IS
NOW SPIRALING OUT OF
CONTROL.
EVERYTHING THAT WE HAVE
WARNED YOU ABOUT IS NOW
COMING TO FRUITION.
AND MUELLER HAS OSTENSIBLY
TONIGHT DECLARED WAR AGAINST
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES.
CLEARLY HIS OBJECTIVE IS TO
REMOVE HIM FROM OFFICE.
I HAVE TOLD YOU HAVE AND I
V. TOLD ANYONE WHO WILL
LISTEN.
MUELLER'S TEAM IS CORRUPT
STARTING WITH HIM AND IT HAS
BEEN FROM THE BEGINNING.
NOW, SHOW US THE EVIDENCE OF
COLLUSION OR THIS
INVESTIGATION NEEDS TO END.
ULTIMATELY, MUELLER'S RUN
AWAY INVESTIGATION CAN ALL
BE TRACED BACK TO ONE
UNFORTUNATE ACT.
THE PRESIDENT ALLUDED TO.
THIS THE ATTORNEY GENERAL,
JEFF SESSIONS, RECUSING
HIMSELF FROM THE RUSSIA
INVESTIGATION LEAVING ROD
ROSENSTEIN, LET'S SEE
MUELLER'S BEST FRIEND,
COMEY'S BEST FRIEND.
MCCABE'S BEST FRIEND TO ACT
IN HIS BEHALF.
IS HE BASICALLY THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL.
AND TONIGHT AS THIS
INVESTIGATION IS NOW
SPIRALING OUT OF CONTROL, IT
IS TIME TO START MAKING
MOVES, PERHAPS, MAYBE EVEN
LIKE CONGRESSMAN MARK
MEADOWS SUGGESTED,
IMPEACHING ROSENSTEIN.
WE WILL EXPLAIN THAT LATER
IN THE PROGRAM.
THIS LEADS US DIRECTLY BY
THE WAY TO OUR NEXT STORY,
THE SLOW RELEASE OF THESE
SUBPOENAED DOCUMENTS FROM
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT TO
THE HOUSE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE.
THE HOUSE INTEL COMMITTEE,
REGARDING THE FBI-CLINTON
EMAIL INVESTIGATION.
AND THE POTENTIAL FISA
ABUSES DURING THE
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL, JEFF
SESSIONS APPOINTED A U.S.
ATTORNEY TO OVERSEE THE
DELIVERY OF MORE THAN
1.2 MILLION DOCUMENTS.
SO FAR THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT HAS OFFERED 3,000
AND 600.
THAT'S IT.
WHY ARE THEY SLOW WALKING?
WHY AREN'T THEY HANDING OVER
WHAT CONGRESS HAS SUBPOENAED
AND IT IS THEIR
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO LOOK
AT VIS-A-VIS OVERSIGHT.
ACCORDING TO A NEW REPORT
TONIGHT FROM SARA CARTER,
QUOTE.
SOME LAWYERS ARE NOW SAYING
THE DOJ'S APPOINTMENT IS FOG
BUT POLITICAL THEATER TO
AVOID CONTEMPT OF CONGRESS.
MAKE NO MISTAKE, THESE
DOCUMENTS ARE CRUCIAL IF
WE'RE GOING TO FIND ANSWERS
ABOUT HOW THE OBAMA JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT UNDER LORETTA
LYNCH AND THE FBI DIRECTOR
JAMES COMEY HANDLED OR
RATHER MISHANDLED THE
CLINTON INVESTIGATION.
THESE DOCUMENTS WILL SHED
LIGHT ON HOW HILLARY WAS
CLEARED OF ALL CHARGES.
I HAVE NEVER HEARD OF AN
EXONERATION BEFORE AN
INVESTIGATION BEFORE AND I
DOUBT ANY OF YOU HAVE AS
WELL.
THESE DOCUMENTS COULD SHOW
HOW THE FISA SYSTEM WAS USED
TO SPY ON A PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGN.
AND HOW THEY LIED TO FISA
COURT JUSTICE.
WHY WON'T THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT RELEASE THE
UNREDACTED FBI MEMO THAT
DEVIN NUNES OF THE HOUSE
INTEL COMMITTEE HAS BEEN
DEMANDING?
WHAT WAS USED, OF COURSE, TO
JUSTIFY THE ENTIRE RUSSIA
COLLUSION INVESTIGATION TO
BEGIN WITH?
NOW, THIS IS MORE THAN
FRUSTRATING AND JUST ONE
MORE EXAMPLE THAT WE NOW
LIVE IN A COUNTRY WITH A TWO
TIERED JUSTICE SYSTEM.
THIS IS WHAT I HAVE BEEN
WARNING YOU ABOUT.
THE FBI IS MORE THAN CAPABLE
OF TRACING A RUSSIA
COLLUSION INVESTIGATION SOME
THOUSAND A PORN STAR AND
DOOR OF DONALD TRUMP'S
PERSONAL ATTORNEY, MICHAEL
COHEN.
BUT THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
OF THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA IS SLOW-WALKING AND
PURPOSEFULLY NOT EVEN
RELEASING DOCUMENTS THEY
HAVE IN THEIR POSSESSION.
THAT HAS BEEN SUBPOENAED BY
THE UNITED STATES CONGRESS,
THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE, THE
INTEL COMMITTEE.
IT IS SHAMEFUL.
THIS SHOULD ALARM EVERY
PERSON WATCHING THIS
BROADCAST TONIGHT.
WE'LL HAVE A LOT MORE ON
THAT IN A FEW MINUTES.
ALAN DERSHOWITZ, SARA CARTER
AND GREGG JARRETT ARE ALL
HERE.
WHILE THE MEDIA ARE
OBSESSING OVER MICHAEL COHEN
THERE ARE IMPORTANT STORIES
TO BRING TO YOU.
OVER THE WEEKEND,ACCORDING
TO MULTIPLE REPORTS ON THE
GROUND ANTI-ASSAD SUBURB OF
DAMASCUS WAS SUBJECT TO A
DEADLY CHEMICAL WEAPONS
ATTACK.
HORRIFIC VIDEO.
CAPTURED FROM THE SCENE.
IT SHOWS MEN.
IT SHOWS WOMEN.
IT SHOWS CHILDREN GASPING
FOR AIR, FOAMING AT THE
MOUTH, WITH MANY LAYING ON
THE GROUND DEAD FROM WHAT
APPEARS TO BE, YET, ANOTHER
GAS ATTACK FROM THE ASSAD
REGIME AGAINST THEIR OWN
PEOPLE.
AND AS WE SPEAK, THE
PRESIDENT IS ONCE AGAIN
WEIGHING HIS OPTIONS IN SIR
YARKSZ AND HERE'S WHAT THE
PRESIDENT SAID ABOUT THIS
EARLIER TODAY.
>> WE'RE GOING TO MAKE A
DECISION TONIGHT OR VERY
SHORTLY THEREAFTER AND
YOU'LL BE HEARING THE
DECISION.
BUT, WE CAN'T LET ATROCITIES
LIKE WE ALL WITNESSED AND
YOU CAN SEE THAT AND IT'S
HORRIBLE.
WE CAN'T LET THAT HAPPEN IN
OUR WORLD WE CAN'T LET THAT
HAPPEN.
ESPECIALLY WHEN WE ARE ABLE,
TO BECAUSE OF THE POWER OF
THE UNITED STATES, BECAUSE
OF THE POWER OF OUR COUNTRY,
WE ARE ABLE TO STOP IT.
WE HAVE A LOT OF OPTIONS,
MILITARILY.
AND WE'LL BE LETTING YOU
KNOW PRETTY SOON.
>> THANKS, EVERYBODY.
THANK YOU ALL.
>> PROBABLY AFTER THE FACT.
>> Sean: NOW, ACCORDING TO
GENERAL MATTIS, ALL OPTIONS
WERE ON THE TABLE INCLUDING
A MILITARY RESPONSE IN
SYRIA.
EARLIER TODAY, THE PRESIDENT
SAID HE WOULD MAKE A
DECISION IN THE NEXT 24 TO
48 HOURS.
RUSSIA AND IRAN ARE NOW
COMING TO ASSAD'S DEFENSE,
DENYING ASSAD ACTUALLY
LAUNCHED THE CHEMICAL
ATTACK.
AND AS I HAVE SAID MANY
TIMES ON THIS PROGRAM, JUST
ONE MORE REASON THIS FLAWED
IRANIAN NUCLEAR DEAL NEEDS
TO BE CANCELLED IMMEDIATELY.
I BELIEVE THE PRESIDENT WILL
DO THAT SOON.
NOW, AS THE PRESIDENT SAID,
RUSSIA SHOULD BE PAYING A
BIG PRICE FOR SUPPORTING
ASSAD, INCLUDING NEW
SANCTIONS AND POLITICAL
RESTRICTIONS.
AND, OF COURSE, THIS COMES A
LITTLE OVER A YEAR AFTER
PRESIDENT TRUMP, REMEMBER,
HE LAUNCHED DOZENS OF CREWS
MISSILES, HEAVILY DAMAGING
AN AIR BASE IN SYRIA AFTER A
SIMILAR GAS ATTACK IN 2017.
AND SADLY THIS ALL COMES
AFTER YEARS OF COMPLETE AND
UTTER TOTAL INACTION FROM
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION.
REMEMBER OBAMA'S IMAGINARY
RED LINE IN THE SAND AND THE
PRICE WE HAVE NOW PAID.
THIS GOES BACK TO 2012.
>> WE HAVE COMMUNICATED IN
NO UNCERTAIN TERMS WHAT
EVERY PLAYER IN THE REGION
THAT THAT'S A RED LINE FOR
US.
AND THAT THERE WOULD BE
ENORMOUS CONSEQUENCES IF WE
START SEEING MOVEMENT ON THE
CHEMICAL WEAPONS FRONT OR
THE USE OF CHEMICAL WEAPONS.
THAT WOULD CHANGE MY
CALCULATIONS SIGNIFICANTLY.
>> Sean: OF COURSE THE RED
LINE WAS CROSSED.
OBAMA'S BLUFF WAS CALLED AND
REGION FELL INTO COMPLETE
AND UTTER CHAOS WITH MANY
SUBSEQUENT GAS ATTACKS TO
FOLLOW.
THEN IN 2013, THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION STRUCK AN
UTTERLY LAUGHABLE DIPLOMATIC
AGREEMENT WITH THE ASSAD,
WHICH GUARANTEED REMOVAL OF
WEAPONS FROM SYRIA.
OKAY I GUESS THEY ARE NOT
GONE.
AS IT TURNS OUT MURDEROUS
DICTATORS ARE NOT EXACTLY
TRUSTWORTHY AND OBAMA'S
STRATEGY IN SYRIA TOTAL
FAILURE LEFT TO THE
PRESIDENT NOW RECTIFY.
WITH ACTION NOW EMINENT IN
SYRIA TONIGHT.
WE WILL BRING YOU ANY
BREAKING DEVELOPMENTS AS
THEY HAPPEN.
ALSO TONIGHT IN AN ATTEMPT
TO GET AHEAD OF JAMES
COMEY'S PENDING BOOK TOUR,
THE FORMER ATTORNEY GENERAL,
LORETTA LYNCH IS NOW
SPEAKING OUT, TRYING TO
EXPLAIN SOME OF, WELL, HER
UNUSUAL AND POTENTIALLY
ILLEGAL ACTIONS DURING THE
FBI'S CLINTON EMAIL
INVESTIGATION BACK IN 2016.
REMEMBER, WHEN LORETTA LYNCH
DIRECTED THE FBI DIRECTOR
JAMES COMEY TO CALL
CLINTON'S CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION A, QUOTE:
MATTER, NOT AN
INVESTIGATION.
AND HE LISTENED.
NOW, TAKE A LOOK AT HOW SHE
NOW TRIES TO EXPLAIN THIS
AWAY.
ALL WHILE THROWING POOR
JAMES COMEY UNDER THE BUS
BEFORE HIS BOOK TOUR.
THIS WAS AN INTERVIEW WITH
MSNBC NEWS.
>> THIS WAS A VERY SENSITIVE
INVESTIGATION AS EVERYONE
KNEW.
AND THE ISSUE HE AND I SAT
DOWN AT THAT TIME WHICH I
THINK WAS EARLY IN THE FALL
OF 2015, WAS WHETHER OR NOT
WE WERE READY AT THE
DEPARTMENT TO CONFIRM AN
INVESTIGATION GOING ON.
WHEN WE TYPICALLY DO NOT
CONFIRM OR DENY
INVESTIGATIONS INTO ANYTHING
WITH RARE EXCEPTIONS.
>> COMEY SAYS CALL IT A
CLINTON MATTER.
HE WANTED TO CALL IT AN
INVESTIGATION.
TO THE EXTENT THAT HE NOTED
IT, THAT IT BOTHERED HIM,
DID HE GO TO YOU AND
QUESTION YOUR CREDIBILITY
WITH REGARD TO THE CLINTON
CASE?
>> WELL, I CAN TELL YOU
THAT, YOU KNOW, IT WAS A
MEETING LIKE ANY OTHER THAT
WE HAD HAD WHERE WE TALKED
ABOUT THE ISSUES.
WE HAD A FULL AND OPEN
DISCUSSION ABOUT IT.
>> HE DIDN'T RAISE ANY
CONCERN?